in 2018 the North American box office
has had its share of high-profile bombs
that was so low the worst-performing
star wars movie in the history of Star
Wars and skyscraper the millionth movie
Dwayne Johnson's made this year but
nothing even comes close to the
disastrous performance of the Chinese
film as Zura made with a reported budget
of 113 million dollars
Azura debuted to just 7.1 million
dollars and before the weekend was over
it had been pulled from theaters so why
did China's most expensive movie ever
made bombs so hard at the box office
what is a surah an adaptation of ancient
Tibetan legends and Buddhist mythology
as surah follows a young man who's
discovered he's destined to save a
heavenly dimension which is under attack
by a three-headed king named desura over
the course of his journey he discovers
he's the reincarnation of one of acerous
heads which had lost a hundred years ago
during a previous invasion attempt as
uru is about a hero's journey one that
was pitched as the start of a trilogy
but it doesn't look like any sequels are
coming anytime soon
sabotage Asura's producers are accusing
china's most prominent film review
aggregating websites of letting users
tank the movie ratings with illegitimate
reviews there are three sites in China
that work as he equivalent of Rotten
Tomatoes and Metacritic Asura's early
average score and one was an eight-point
four out of ten while the other two
registered at four point nine and a
three point one what explains that
discrepancy the people behind a surah
are convinced that their movie is the
victim of a focused malicious attack
specifically that producers claim that
they discovered a large number of one
out of ten scores from
suspicious-looking users which were
posted immediately after the film hit
theaters in an official statement they
have announced whoever is behind this is
dirty stupid and ridiculous yanked from
theaters rather than cut their losses
and ride out the storm Asura's
filmmakers decided to snatch their movie
back out of theaters as quickly as
possible only a few other movies have
gotten the hook in China in 2012 Quentin
Tarantino's Django Unchained was
unexpectedly pulled from Chinese
theaters literally minutes after being
released but that was only done for the
sake of censorship and Django returned
to theaters in a matter of weeks after
edits were made Azura's situation is
entirely different it was pulled by the
film's own producers for the drastic
perv
of editing it to somehow make it better
but to appreciably raise the movies
quality through editing would likely
take months as opposed to weeks world
class affects one of us or is biggest
attempted innovations as as larger than
usual focus on special effects this
might seem unusual to American
moviegoers who are used to seeing state
of the art special effects as a matter
of course but in the past
Chinese produced movies typically
haven't had as much money pumped into
them as a result their special effects
often looked embarrassingly cheap Azura
aimed to break that mold it seems no
expense was spared to bring the movie's
effects to the standards set by American
movies that included hiring in-demand
award-winning Hollywood talents
including veterans of Deadpool Lord of
the Rings and Furious 7
but while the money seems to have all
ended up on screen it doesn't appear to
have been a good investment
middling marketing another one of a
service problems it's a sort of thing
that could strike any movie anywhere a
lack of effective marketing
despite six years worth of development
on build up when it came time to
actually sell Azura to potential
audiences it looks like the ball got
dropped at a critical moment at least
that's one claim that's been circulating
stemming from Chinese market analysts
according to a representative of Beijing
based showbiz market research firm bun
King based on our tracking pre-release
market heat for this movie was quite low
below average regardless of whether or
not that's an accurate assessment of the
situation
Azura now has a reputation as a movie
almost that nobody wanted to say
untested director what else could have
gone wrong here for one thing director
Peng Zhang is an untested quantity
though he's been a stunt coordinator for
many Hollywood productions including
Wonder Woman The Last Samurai and rush
hour 3 Azura is his first ever project
as director think about that for a
second what's purported to be the most
expensive film ever made in the history
of China was directed by a person who
had never directed a movie before in his
life
we're not saying Asura's failure is
sangs false we're just pointing out that
a first-time director seems like an
incredibly strange choice to head up
such an expensive high-stakes production
[Music]